now that apple has revealed and released
their new macbook pros with the m1 pro
and m1 max chips we can finally get a
better idea of what to expect from the
future apple silicon mac pro so in this
video i'm going to take the existing
leaks and rumors that we already have
for this mac pro and combine them with
what we know about the m1 max chip to
make some predictions in terms of the
general size and design of the mac pro
the price the release date the layout of
the motherboard the situation with the
ram the overall performance and much
more so let's jump right in first of all
mark german recently reminded us that
the mac pro will have a new larger soc
chip with up to 40 cpu cores and
128 gpu cores which is a perfectly
scaled version of the current 10 core m1
max chip with a 32 core gpu and in
previous reports mark confirmed that the
40 core chip will consist of 32 high
performance cores exactly four times the
amount that you get with the m1 max chip
and he also said that it would come with
a less expensive option with a 20 core
cpu and a 64 core gpu which is two times
the amount of the m1 max so just like i
already showed you guys around four
months ago i believe that apple will
quite literally take two or four m1 max
dies and toss them into a single soc
package using some form of new infinity
fabric to interconnect the dies to
create a single extremely powerful chip
but before i get into what that means
for the price and the performance i want
to cover the design but first i want to
mention that only around 27 of you guys
are subscribed so if you didn't already
click that subscribe button below to
help us reach our goal of 1 million subs
before the end of the year now getting
into the design a lot of people are
expecting the new mac pro to look like a
cube but that's actually based on a
pretty old rumor from mark german from
way back in january when he said it
would resemble the old apple power mac
g4 cube but if you look at a more recent
report from german in may he changed his
mind and he now believes that it'll look
like a smaller version of the current
mac pro design which to me makes the
most sense because the current design of
the mac pro is now iconic so here's an
image of what i expected to look like
being around 33 smaller than the current
model now you might be wondering how
apple is gonna have enough room for all
of the components if they're making it
that much smaller well if you think
about it there are four different things
that take up the most amount of space
inside of the current mac pro number one
is the two massive mpx modules for
graphics number two is the huge cpu
heatsink for that crazy power hungry 28
core xeon cpu
number three is the large and thick
triple fan system that covers the entire
face of the front of the mac pro and
number four is the pretty hefty 1.4
kilowatt power supply so to tackle
number one first i fully believe that
the new mac pro will not support the
current mpx modules because i can 100
guarantee you that third-party gpus like
the ones from amd will not be supported
on the new mac pro or any apple silicon
mac ever so with that said the new mac
pro will likely only have four or six
pci express slots so that professionals
can add in things like audio interface
cards io cards blackmagic deck link
cards and potentially custom apple gpu
cards if apple decides to make them but
even if they do they will no longer be
double wide cards like the current mpx
slots they'll probably only take up a
single slot just like the current
afterburner card now on to number two
that massive cpu heatsink may not need
to be that large anymore because as we
all know apple's chips are extremely
power efficient and that same reasoning
applies to the huge triple fan system
which i believe can be easily slimmed
down on the new mac pro and finally for
number four we have the absolutely
overkill 1.4 kilowatt power supply that
we will no longer need and i know this
for a fact because the highest package
power reported on the new m1 max macbook
pro has been 92 watts total and keep in
mind that's with andre from inentech
putting as much load as possible on the
chip including the cpu and the gpu at
the same time so if you multiply that by
four assuming the mac pro will have four
of these m1 max dies that brings the
power usage up to
368 watts and that's for the
top-of-the-line chat now keep in mind
that our 12 core xeon mac pro which is
slower than the 30 watt cpu in the m1
pro chip was able to use up to 218 watts
by itself let me repeat that that's just
the xeon cpu alone the 92 watt total
package power in the m1 max also
includes the gpu the neural engine the
media encoders the thunderbolt display
engines the amx co-processors the memory
buses the unified ram all of the
different caches and literally
everything else but then taking it even
further with the current mac pro the
highest nw 6900x gpu uses around 300 to
350 watts alone and then the
w6800x duo likely uses up to 500 watts
total that's more than the theoretical
maximum of 368 watts for the four m1 max
dies and that's including the cpu and
everything else so the point that i'm
making is that apple no longer needs a
crazy large power supply especially
since they won't support amd graphics
cards anymore so with that design stuff
out of the way i want to get into how i
can see apple pulling off this new 40
core m1 max quadro chip which is a name
that many other people on twitter can
agree on as we already know apple is
using a binning process to improve
yields for their chips as you can see in
this analysis by frederick orange on
twitter so for example if there are too
many defects on the bottom m1 max
portion of the die apple literally
slices off the bottom and uses it as an
m1 pro chip or if there are up to two
defective performance cores on the top
apple sells it as an 8 core base m1 pro
chip in the base 14 inch model and even
better apple secretly printed a second
neural engine on the bottom m1 max
portion just in case the one on the top
is defective to then sell it as an m1
max ship to improve yields which is
genius so my theory is that over the
next year apple is going to be
collecting perfect m1 max dies with no
flaws at all so they can be put together
in the mac pro by creating that m1 max
quadro chip by using a larger io die for
connecting them in some sort of infinity
fabric to minimize efficiency loss and
the cool thing about using perfect m1
max dies is that apple can technically
enable the second 16 core neural engine
within each die giving us up to an
insane
128 core neural engine across all of the
four m1 max dies if they really wanted
to but to make things even better the
new m1 max quadro chip will technically
have eight video encoders and decoders
as well as eight pro res encoders in
decoders so for example matthew moniz
made a video where he compared the m1
max macbook pro to a custom built
desktop pc with the brand new i9 12 900k
alder lake cpu and an rtx 3080 desktop
gpu and in his davinci resolve export
test the macbook pro smoked the desktop
pc by finishing in just a minute and 59
seconds but with eight video encoders
and decoders the m1 max quadro and the
future mac pro would finish the export
in only around 30 seconds basically
being six times faster than this rtx
3080 desktop pc which basically will
create the world's fastest computer for
video editing by far but what really
blew my mind is a programming test that
matthew ran which was compiling mozilla
firefox apparently the 10 core m1 max
chip only took one minute longer than
the alder lake 12900k which is
absolutely mind-blowing because that cpu
is now the world's fastest non-server
consumer cpu in terms of raw performance
being over two times faster than the m1
max but in this compiled test the m1 max
is barely slower because of the
efficient unified memory architecture in
fact in our xcode programming test the
10 core m1 max was only 4 seconds slower
than the insanely expensive 28 core xeon
in the current mac pro so imagine how
fast the 40 core m1 max quadro will be
in a future mac pro and just to use some
quick math the 40 core cpu could score
up to 49 348 points in cinebench r23 if
it scaled linearly but just in case i'm
going to take off 10 for efficiency loss
giving us a score of 44
400 points basically creating the
world's fastest non-server grade cpu
competing with some of the highest end
amd threadripper cpus out there but
going even further the crazy thing is
that the new m1 max quadro chip will
also have eight amx chips for matrix
multiplication it's going to have a 128
channel memory for overkill photo
editing performance and it should have
16 thunderbolt 4 controllers to support
up to a theoretical total of 12 6k
displays and 4 4k displays using hdmi
and then of course you'll have up to 256
gigs of unified memory and 128
powerful gpu cores so if you're curious
about how that crazy gpu would perform
we can actually get a rough estimate if
we take a look at the performance of the
m1 max in the optimized 3d mark wildlife
extreme benchmark the 32 core m1 max
scored almost exactly four times higher
than the eight core gpu in the m1
showing that apple achieved perfect four
time scaling in optimized workflows so
if we assume perfect four time scaling
going from a single 32 core m1 max die
up to 128 cores in an m1 max quadro chip
that would bring the score up to over 80
000 which is absolutely insane but just
to be realistic let's factor in 10
efficiency loss due to the fact that the
four dies will have to communicate over
some form of infinity fabric that brings
us down to around 73 000 points which is
actually higher than the best score ever
recorded in this 3dmark wildlife
benchmark which is 61973
using an i9 109900k and an rtx 3090 gpu
however that gpu was overclocked like
crazy with the clock speed sitting at
2.8 gigahertz compared to the base 1.4
gig frequency as well as slightly
overclocked memory speed as well but if
we adjust the boost clock speeds down to
a more realistic 1.8 gigahertz that most
of these 3090s ship with we see scores
of around 45 000 points compared to an
estimated 73 000 for the future mac pro
so the point that i'm making is that
even the integrated 128 core gpu and
this new m1 max quadro mac pro would be
the fastest consumer gpu in the world
and that's not even looking into
performance per watt metrics so based on
that i honestly don't think that apple
needs to create custom apple gpu add-in
cards but if for some reason they do
they can potentially reuse m1 max dies
that had too many flaws in other parts
of the die and simply use them to create
custom gpu chips with disabled cpu cores
but with all of that out of the way the
last point that i want to make is that a
fully loaded new mac pro will be less
expensive than the current ones so
getting into it the reason that the
current 28 core xeon cpu in the mac pro
is insanely expensive is because it
features a massive monolithic dye that
has low yields because those huge dies
take up a larger portion of the silicon
wafer so you're wasting more of the
edges of the wafer and losing dies due
to flaws but if you look at something
like apple's m1 ship the price per die
is much cheaper because they're much
smaller estimated by lacuza on twitter
to be 120 square millimeters so there's
a lot less wasted wafer space so fredrik
orange on twitter made an estimate of
the price per die and it comes out to
200 per m1 max die based on a 60 yield
rate because this is a newly designed
chip bringing the total up to 800
for four of these dies which is likely
much lower than one of those monolithic
28 core xeon dies which doesn't even
include all of the other components like
the crazy 128 core gpu and everything
else so because apple is going to be
combining multiple m1 max dies they're
saving a ton of cash compared to using
monolithic dies which means that the
price that we as consumers have to pay
will drop by a lot but with that said
let's finally get into what i expect
apple to pack into the base model as
well as the pricing and the release date
mark german believes that you'll have
two main chip options for the mac pro
the 20 core model which i think will be
called the m1 max duo and the 40 core
model or the m1 max quadro so for the
base model i expect it to come with a 20
core cpu a bend 48 core gpu that can be
upgraded to 64 cores 64 gigs of unified
memory that can be upgraded to 128 gigs
and a one terabyte ssd that can be
upgraded up to 16 terabytes and
potentially optional dedicated
traditional ram if they choose to add
that in for specific workloads and as
for my estimates for the base price i
think it'll start anywhere from four
thousand to six thousand dollars and
then upgrading from the base chip to the
top of the line 40 core chip with 128
gpu cores and 256 gigs of ram will cost
somewhere around 8 000
for that crazy upgrade which is
significantly cheaper than the cpu and
gpu upgrades on the current mac pro and
then of course you've got to add in
storage upgrades and potentially
traditional ram upgrades and maybe even
add in custom gpu cards if apple decides
to go that route as well but of course
this is all just speculation but one
thing i do know for sure is that the new
mac pro will likely go up for sale in
either november or december of next year
just in time for business right off
season so there you guys go hopefully i
was able to put some things into
perspective and i want to mention that i
fully believe that this apple silicon
mac pro will be the fastest consumer
available computer in the world
by far for both professional work and
gaming basically giving you a super
computer at home so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]